everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm in today we are in around
two of our coverage at the 2019 a grand
prix from latvia we have eight players
remaining in this tournaments the round
two we are in the second game so each of
these rounds is a heads-up match and
they play the best of two series so each
side has white once and then after two
games if they are still tied so two wins
or two draws then we go into a
tiebreaker and then they will play down
until there is an eventual winner it
could end up in Armageddon but they do
play six tiebreaker games but today we
are going to be looking at a game
between Wesley so inserting a card yakun
Wesley so is gonna be playing the white
pieces he defended yesterday with the
black pieces and they drew Sergei Kelly
I can will be playing the black pieces
today trying to hold on for draw and go
to tie breakers or even get the victory
with the black pieces we definitely have
seen some sides win with the black
pieces in this tournament but both sides
looking to go to the final four in this
very important tournament with the race
two potential people moving on to the
candidates tournaments here next year to
see who will face Magnus Carlsen for the
World Championship so we'll go ahead and
get started Wesley starts out starts out
with pawn to d4 a knight f6 upon c4 pani
six Knight c3 and Bishop b4 this is the
nimzo-indian offense and a lot of
players from white try to avoid this
line because black has such a strong
attacking line and they just don't like
to have a double pawns here on the C
file typically a backwards pawn here on
the C file that they have to deal with
and by just has a really good game in
this spot so many times you'll even see
a delayed opening from white sometimes
Knight to f3 in the spots maybe even
pawn III solidifying the pawn chain
waiting to see what this Bishop does if
this bishop does come down here then it
has some additional options or
maybe even the night coming down to d2
or Bishop d2 and not getting the night
up here but in the game we do see the
standard nimzo-indian defense and then
pawn f3 now this is not common most
common is gonna be pawn III here and
just as I'm gonna solidify the pawn
chain here if you want to take that's
fine I'll just clog up the center of the
board with my pawns but we see pawn f3
preparing to push forward with E for
here and just say I want to dominate the
center of the board if you want to give
me an extra pawn the center that is
completely okay Sergei is looking to
counter-attack in the seer the board
pawn e4 is where white wants to go so he
recognizes that and starts to push
forward a3 here pushing the bishop back
and then Bishop comes back to e7 really
expected him to just take here on c3 one
of the main reasons you play the members
of any defense is to play this move
right here after the pawn recaptures you
can castle on the King side you have a
very solid setup right here he decides
and said to go ahead and play Bishop to
e7 and then Pawnee 4 as we expected
there is an exchange on the board and
then c5 trying to break up that Center
and then d5 so black has a cramped
position he's gonna be castling on at
the King side but there's not a lot of
squares for blacks really go to and if
you are gonna extend like Wesley so is
in this board state you need to cut off
as many squares as possible because you
really have no protection in front of
your King right here you haven't even
moved any of the pieces in front of your
King so if that's gonna be the case you
need a strong attack because once Serbia
cardiac can can break through he's a
pretty easy attack on his opponents King
Wesley continues with Bishop to d3 was
really hoping for something crazy 'if
I've stood out to me as I was analyzing
the game Knight d7 you could see some
crazy shenanigans Knight to f3 exchange
here in the stern of the board maybe the
Knights come off the board Bishop down
h4 pawn g3 attacking that but then rook
to e8 pinning down this knight here
'if I've this would have been pretty fun
but in the game probably a little safer
to play I was just fun for me but that's
okay Bishop to d3 bishop to a d6 and
then Bishop g5 pinning down this night
here on f6 so stopping a lot of the
squares that black can even go to and
then now pinning down at this knight on
f6 Knight to d7 but this does also limit
some of the squares this light square
bishop can go to eventually we want to
play bishop or pawn b6 scuse me and they
get the light squared bishop involved
into the game we'll have to break up the
stern of the board if he wants to bring
it here to b7
really wasn't do too much here on a6
right now at least Knight to f3 just
getting involved into the game pun takes
on d5 we do see exchange on the board
and then pawn h6 says we've got to kick
this bishop off right now don't want to
have to worry about that anymore Bishop
to h4 and then Queen a 5 because this
Knights being pinned down really wants
to move it but he first knows that he
can't move until the Queen moves this is
a pretty easy way to get the Queen
involved to check your opponent's and
the Queen comes to d2 after the Queen
takes couple options white could
absolutely take with his knight right
here but this is a pretty good square
for the knight it's develop move
controlling the center of the board so
he takes with his King here on D - once
the Queen's come off the board it is
pretty common for both sides to get
their Kings involved into the game you
can't really have some crazy
checkmate without the Queen it's
possible it's just not very common and
so decide to take with his King no
longer look into castle but from the
beginning it didn't really look like
that was his strategy you just want to
be extremely aggressive with his pieces
block a lot of those squares that black
can go to and see what happens from
there
Knight to g4 just trying to get involved
into the Kings side the board Bishop e7
attacking the rook here says let's go in
exchange material that's exactly what
happens
nightly 7 check King here to h8 rook to
e1 centralizing 95 attacking the bishop
and then rook to d1 now in this setup I
think both sides are pretty equal black
has a lot of different options here
pawn beasts
as we talked about solidifying the pawn
chain what I did not expect to see is
after nineteen moves the players decided
to draw and go into tie breakers
tomorrow and that is the the end of the
game and if you're looking to say oh my
gosh was there not another game that
could have gone over honestly there was
a lot of draws today for draws in the
matches and one of the games went 11-5
the other moves and that was surprising
because that was table verse MV Ellen
Toby loves playing for his life MBL won
in the first round we looked at that
game yesterday Game one in round two so
MBL will be moving on after the draw
today didn't even play after 11 moves
that was definitely surprising to me but
in this game Wesley so in circuit card I
can play an exciting game up to this
point I was really curious to see how
this would play out with the set up we
just don't see it too often in the
nimzo-indian defense but we will have to
wait another day to see who will move on
to the Final Four in this tournament so
we have a short one today but we will be
back tomorrow for the tie breakers we
have three tiebreaker rounds in the set
up getting to the font for but thank you
guys for watching the short video today
we'll be back tomorrow thanks again